[موسيقى]
مساء الخير تجاوبا ما عدد كبير من اسئله
وتعليقات اصدقائنا في المغرب نخصص حلقه
اليوم لقضيه الصحراء وبنحاول في هذه
الحلقه
ايضاح حقيقه موقف المجتمع الدولي من
الصحراء
وموقف الولايات المتحده تحديدا الان
ولماذا تحظى هذه القضيه بكل هذه الاهميه
للمغاربه لماذا يصعب ان تظهر حلول وسط
لهذه القضيه التي تسمم علاقات المغرب
والجزائر وتوتر علاقات المملكه بكثير من
دول العالم المغرب بتضع كل من يشكك في
سياده المغرب على الصحراء في قائمه سوداء
لكن الاجابه على كل هذه الاسئله بتقتدي ان
نعرف ابتداء ما هي قضيه الصحراء ولو خصصنا
هذه الحلقه لجذور المشكله هناخد الحلقه
كلها لكن احنا اتكلمنا عن جذور المشكله في
حلقات سابقه سوف اضع لكم روابطها استاذنكم
ان تعودوا اليها حتى لا نكرر رجاء فيها
ولكن اذكركم بشكل سريع ارجو ان لا يكون
مخلا احتلت اسبانيا الصحراء التي تبلغ
مساحتها حوالي 266 الف كيلو مترا مربعا
ولها اطلاله طويله جدا على المحيط
الاطلنطي وتحتوي على ثروات طبيعيه هائله
خصوصا ثروات الفوسفات
احتلتها اسبانيا عام
وظلت محتله لهذه الصحراء التي سميت لاحقا
بالصحراء الاسبانيه حتى اضطرت للانسحاب
عنها في منتصف السبعينات يعني اخر 75 اول
عام
1976 لاسباب يطول شرحها لكن في السنوات
اللي سبقت قرار الانسحاب الاسباني كان
هناك مشكله كبيره ماذا تفعل اسبانيا بهذه
المستعمره السابقه هل تتركها للسحراويين
او جبهه البوليساريو التي تشكلت كجبهه
مقاومه للاحتلال الاسباني وجبهه
البوليساريو ترغب فيه
الاستقلال بالصحراء واقامه دوله مستقله هل
تجري عليها استفتاء حول تقرير المصير قد
يفضي ايضا الى انفصال الصحراويين وتاسيس
دوله مستقله عن المغرب
ام تترك الصحراء للمغرب
وموريتانيا ليه المغرب وموريتانيا لان
الدولتين دول اعلنوا في السنوات اللي سبقت
الانسحاب الاسباني ان هذه الارض ارضهم
موريتانيا انسحبت لاحقا من هذه الادعاءات
وظلت المغرب متمسكه بمغربيه الصحراء
باختصار شديد جدا
الخلاف الموجود على قضيه الصحراء بين
طرفين اساسيين المغرب يقول ان الصحراء
مغربيه لا مراء في ذلك
وجبهه البوليساريو تقول ان الصحراء
صحراءنا وعليها اقمنا الجمهوريه العربيه
الصحراويه الديمقراطيه في
1976 وحول الموقفين تنقسم دول العالم لكن
انا حابب في هذه الحلقه ان اجيب على كثير
من هذه الاسئله باستعراض وثيقه اعدتها او
المخابرات الامريكيه في ديسمبر 1977 ورفعت
عنها السريه في نوفمبر 2012 الوثائق
الخاصه بالمخابرات الغربيه وغير الغربيه
يعني وزارات الخارجيه لاسبانيا وفرنسا
وامريكا وغيرهم كثيره لكن هذه الوثيقه
واحده من الوثائق
اللي بتكشف بقدر كبير من الدقه عده امور
منها اهميه الصحراء للمغرب ومنها اسباب
دعم الجزائر على الاقل من وجهه نظر واشنطن
لجبهه البوليساريو اللي بترغب في الانفصال
عن المغرب وتاسيس دوله مستقله لها على هذه
الصحراء
وثالث هذه الاسباب او ثالث يعني المحاور
في هذه الوثيقه انها بتكشف تصور امريكا
المبكر لمسار هذا الصراع الى الوثيقه ثم
الملاحظات بتبدا الوثيقه بتوضيح مهم لصناع
القرار في واشنطن
بتجمع معلومات بتعمل عمليه تقدير موقف
لصناع القرار الوثيقه بتبدا بتوضيح مهم
جدا لصناع القرار في واشنطن ان ضم الصحراء
للمغرب يحظى بدعم كل شرائح المجتمع
المغربي هذا ليس الملك ولا نخب ولا رجال
اعمال هذا قرار او رغبه بتحضر بدعم كل
شرائح المجتمع المغربي
وانه عمليه الضم او المطالبه بالصحراء
بتستند لاسس تاريخيه ودينيه عميقه وان
قضيه الصحراء لها انعكاسات مهمه على
استقرار النظام السياسي في المغرب كما ان
الموقف من الصحراء مرتبط ايضا بشكل مباشر
بقدره المغرب على منافسه جارته اللدوده
الجزائر نتيجه لذلك الوثيقه بتقول في
المقدمه من غير المعقول ان يتمكن الملك
الحسن وقتها في 1977 من التراجع عن قضيه
سياده المغرب على الصحراء اذا فعل ذلك
فسوف اخاطره بفقدان شرعيته وبتشرح الوثيقه
جذور الحوس كما سمته الحوس المغربي
بالصحراء على النحو التالي
اي تفسير للسياسه المغربيه تجاه الصحراء
على انها مجرد رغبه في الاستيلاء على
اراضي تمنحها هيمنه على سوق الفوسفات
العالمي غير دقيق صحراء فيها اكبر مخزون
حتى الان مكتشف او معروف يعني من الفوسفات
وبالتالي من يسيطر على الاقليم يسيطر على
سوق الفوسفات ومن يسيطر على سوق الفوسفات
يسيطر على معدن المؤثر جدا في الزراعه وفي
الطاقه الى اخره
الوثيقه بتقول لا ده مش هو ده السبب
مطالبه مش هو ده السبب الرئيسي مطالبه
المغرب بالصحراء مبني على اعتبارات تمتد
بعمق في تاريخ هذه الامه فقبل فتره
الاستعمار الفرنسي والاسباني مارس الحكام
المغاربه درجات متفاوته من السيطره على
جزء كبير من شمال وغرب افريقيا لانه من
القرن العاشر حتى القرن ال17 تغلغل النفوذ
المغربي المملكه المغربيه في الصحراء
الغربيه
وموريتانيا وجنوب غرب الجزائر وحتى مالي
والوثيقه بتقول ان منذ استقلالي استقلال
مين استقلال المغرب عام 1956 شكل مغاربته
من ان القوى الغربيه الاستعماريه وتحديدا
فرنسا واسبانيا خلال فتره الاستعمار لشمال
افريقيا جردوا المغرب من اجزاء كبيره من
اراضيه التاريخيه افتح قوسين الوثيقه
بتقول وشكوى المغاربه لها ما يبررها يعني
هي بتؤيد ما ذهب اليه المغاربه من انه
اسبانيا وفرنسا جردوا المغرب من اراضي كان
يجب ان تكون واقعه للان تحت حدودهم
بالمناسبه تصديقا لما ذهبت اليه الوثيقه
المغرب لم يتخلى عن مطالبه بكامل
موريتانيا الا في عام 1970
وقبل التفاوض مع الجزائر لتحديد الحدود
الجنوبيه الشرقيه بينهما اي تخلى عن
مطالبه في الصحراء الشرقيه فقط في عام
1972 ولكن دي قصه يطول شرحها الوثيقه او
السي اي ايه بتقول انه على الرغم من
الحنين والمطالب التي تظهر احيانا من جانب
قوى قوميه في المغرب لاستعاده المغرب
الكبير لكن غالبيه المغاربه قد قبلوا
خساره اجزاء كبيره من اراضيهم قبل
الاستعمار كامرا واقع لكن هذا التسليم لم
يمتد ابدا للصحراء الغربيه التي بقت
استثناء ملحوظا في عقول المغاربه وقلوبهم
فمنذ اوائل السبعينات
ركزت تيار المغربي القومي على قضيه
الصحراء واعتبرها فرصه المغرب الاخيره
لاستعاده بعضا من اراده المنهوبه
الوثيقه بتوضح ان مطالبه المغرب بالصحراء
لا تستندوا الى التعريف الغربي للسياده
وانما الى مفهوم البيعه المتجذر في
الثقافه الاسلاميه ضيعه ملي من بيعه قبائل
المنطقه اللي هي الصحراء لملك او حاكم
المغرب في فترات زمنيه متعدده
ودعم هذا المنطق سيطره المغرب على الصحراء
في فترات تاريخيه كثيره
ونتيجه لذلك الوثيقه بتقول فان جميع شرائح
الشعب المغربي تؤيد بشكل ساحق عداله مطالب
المغرب وسياسته تجاه الصحراء
بيقولوا انه لقضيه المغرب ابعاد اخرى
لان هيكون لها تاثير عميق على استقرار
النظام السياسي المغربي
وبيقول انه الحمله القوميه لاستعاده
الاراضي المنهوبه يقصد تحديدا الصحراء
الغربيه بدا او انطلقت في ظل مغرب منقسم
بشده على نفسه في منتصف الستينات منقسم
على نفسه وغير واثق غير واثق من مين من
قياده الملك الحسن اللي كان تولى منصبه
كملك سنه 61 وطبعا ظل فيه الى 38 سنه حتى
وافته المانيه في عام 1999
والوثيقه بتقول انه الملك اللي كان بيواجه
معارضه وانقسمات وتوتر في المجتمع اطلق
حمله استعاده الصحراء وبمجرد اطلاق هذه
الحمله تعزز الشعبيته بشكل كبير جدا وسحب
البوصات من تحت اقدام المعارضه وانضم كل
خصوم الملك الى معسكرين وقاده جميع
الاحزاب باطيافهم المختلفه
حول العالم لدعم مطالب المغرب في الصحراء
باختصار تبخر الشعور بالانقسام وعدم الثقه
التي كان يسمم السياسه المغربيه في منتصف
الستينات وبدا ان البلاد تستعيد احساسها
بوجود هدف وطني تم اتضح من خلال المسيره
الخضراء سنه 1975 ايه المسيره الخضراء
المسيره اللي دعا اليها الملك انه مئات
الالاف من المغاربه يقتحموا الصحراء
ويؤكدوا بسط السياده المغربيه على الصحراء
يعني بوضع اليد يعني هذه ارضنا وعليه
بتعتبر القياده المغربيه وفقا للوثيقه
قضيه الصحراء بالغه الحساسيه من زاويه
السياسه الداخليه اذا حاول الحسن هكذا
تقول الوثيقه في عام 1977
التراجع عن مطالب المغرب في الصحراء
فسيفقد شرعيته ما قد يمهد الطريق امام
محاوله الانقلابيه اخرى من قبل الجيش
وتتابع الوثيقه اصبحت قضيه الصحراء ايضا
عنصرا مهما في المنافسه الجيو السياسيه
بين المغرب والجزائر التي اشتبكت مع
المملكه في حرب بالوكاله من خلال دعم
البوليساريو الراغبه في الاستقلال
بالصحراء وتشرح الوثيقه الموقف الجزائري
على النحو التالي على الرغم من ان السبب
الظاهري للجزائر لدعم البوليساريو هو مبدا
حق تقرير المصير فان تنافسها التاريخي مع
المغرب على الهيمنه على شمال غرب افريقيا
والدافع الاساسي لها هدف الجزائر في هذا
النزاع هو اقامه جمهوريه صحراويه مستقله
يكون للجزائر نفود كبير عليها وهذا من
شانه ان يحرم المغرب من الموارد
الاقتصاديه الكبيره للاقليم ويحبط جهود
المغرب
لتقييد وصول الجزائر الى المحيط الاطلسي
لو انت مش من اهل المغرب بص على الخريطه
اذا سيطره الجزائر او اذا سيطرت دوله
تابعه على الصحراء فسوف يمكن للجزائر ان
تنفذ مباشره الى سواحل الاطلسي بعيدا عن
المغرب وبتقول الوثيقه باختصار يعارض
بمدين من بومدين هواري بومدين اللي هو
الرئيس الجزائري في ذلك الوقت سياده
المغرب على الصحراء الغربيه لانه يفسد
تطلعات الجزائر للهيمنه على شمال افريقيا
ده وجهه نظر واشنطن وتلخص الوثيقه في
المقابل مخاوف المغرب من التخلي عن
الصحراء يعني بمعنى بتلخص الوثيقه اهميه
الصحراء الاستراتيجيه للمغرب في ثلاثه
نقاط النقطه الاولى
ان انشاء دوله صغيره تابعه للجزائر سيفصل
المغرب عن بقيه افريقيا ما يخلق المغرب او
على حد تعبير الوثيقه سوف يضع حبل المشنقه
حول عنق المغرب اثنين جمهوريه صحراويه
راديكاليه يعني متطرفه اي محسوبه على
اليسار المعادل النظام الملكي ما هو
اليساريين اللي بينتمي اليهم جبهه
البوليساريو هي بتفضل الجمهوريات على
النظام الملكي وتقاوم الملكيات وعليه فهم
بيعتبروها متطرفه ومعاديه للنظام من شان
قيام هذه الجمهوريه مش ان هي بس تبقى
معاديه للمغرب وهتبقى في جمهوريه معاديه
على حدودها ولكنها سوف تكون قاعده تخريبيه
تنطلق منها الجماعات المغربيه الثوريه
المعاديه للنظام ثلاثه فقدان الصحراء سوف
يحرم المغرب من عوائد الفوسفات الهائله
التي تساعده في مباراه الجزائر اللي يعتمد
على عوائد الغاز الكبيره يعني الفوسفات
هنا عند المغرب اللي بياتي من الصحراء سوف
يعادل الثروات التي تتدفق على خصمها
الجزائر من الغاز
العوامل الثلاثه اللي اشاره اليهم الوثيقه
يضاف الى الاعتبار الرابع الذي اشرنا اليه
منذ قليل وهو الخوف من سقوط النظام وتفكك
الجبهه الداخليه اذا تم التخلي عن اقليم
يؤمن كل شرائح المجتمع تقريبا بانه مغربي
خالص وبالتالي باختصار من شان انشاء دوله
تابعه للجزائر في الصحراء تغيير موازين
القوه في شمال افريقيا بشكل دائم لصالح
الجزائر فضلا عن تهديد نظام الحكم في
المغرب وتخلص الوثيقه الى التالي
رؤيتها للحاضر والمستقبل لن يتنازل المغرب
عن مطالبه بالسياده على الصحراء ومن غير
المرجح ان يوافق على اي صيغه تسويه تهدد
مطالبه بالسياده على هذا الاقليم على
الرغم من انه من المرجح ان يكون مرنا من
اللي يكون مرن المغرب فيما يتعلق بالجوانب
الاخرى للتسويه المحتمله وقتها في
السبعينات زي ايه زي الاستغلال المشترك
لموارد الصحراء زي ضمان حريه وصول الجزائر
لشواطئ المحيط الاطلنطي زي العفو عن
مقاتلي البوليساريو الذين قام المغرب
بالقبض عليهم او اسرهم وترى ان المغرب على
استعداد تام لتجاهل ضغوط المجتمع الدولي
ومعه الولايات المتحده اذا اصروا على
المطالبه بحق تقرير المصير للصحراء وبترى
الوثيقه الوثيقه وضعت يعني التصور
لتصرفات المغرب
على المدى القصير اللي هو 18 شهر بس ده
تجاوزه الزمن انما باختصار كده ان في ال
18 شهر من بعد وضع الوثيقه اللي هو يعني
في 78 و 79 سوف
تركز المغرب على
يعني بسط سيطرتها بالقوه العسكريه على
الصحراء وبتقول الوثيقه انه دعم السعوديه
ودعم فرنسا سوف يكون مهما جدا لاستمرار
المملكه في هذه في هذا الاتجاه يعني تعزيز
وجودها العسكري في الصحراء لكن دي تجاوزها
الزمن انما بتقول على المدى البعيد لا
يمكن استبعاد ان تشن المغرب هجوما عسكريا
ضد الجزائر اي تندلعوا حربا بين الدولتين
وبتقول انه ما حاله دون هذه الحرب حتى
الان هو التفوق الواضح للجزائر على المغرب
في المعدات العسكريه الكلام ده سنه سنه
1977 لكن الضغوط بتتزايد على القياده
المغربيه اللي شن عمليه عقابيه ضد
البوليساريو اللي بتتخذ من الاراضي
الجزائريه مقرا لها
خاصه اذا استمرت خسائر الجيش في الصحراء
نتيجه هجوم جبهه البوليساريو المدعومه من
الجزائر
وفي حين انه دوافقه للوسيط الوثيقه من غير
المرجح ان ينتصر المغرب في حرب ضد الجزائر
فان المزاج السائد في المغرب قد يؤدي في
النهايه الى المخاطره بشن عمليه عسكريه ضد
الجزائر حتى تدفع ثمن سياساتها في الصحراء
مجموعه من الملاحظات الوثيقه في تقدير
مهمه ولكنها
تفيض بالتعاطف من جانب الفريق
الامريكي اللي فيه السي اي ايه اللي كان
مسؤول عن المغرب وعن القضيه التعاطف واضح
جدا جدا مع الموقف المغربي وطبعا مش محتاج
اديكم امثله لانه اكيد واصلكم مدى التعاطف
الفريق اللي هو
بقدر الموقف في الصحراء وبيرسلوا الى
المسؤولين في امريكا التعاطف واضح من عده
امور لما كنتش يعني لو كان حضراتكم ما
لاحظتوش يعني التقرير لما يقول انه سياسه
المغرب تجاه الصحراء ليست مبنيه ابدا على
رغبه في الاستيلاء على سوق الفوسفات
ولكنها مبنيه على اعتبارات تمتد بعمق في
تاريخ هذه الامه انه المغرب لازم تفهموا
دوافع مطالبه التي لا تستند الى التعريف
الغربي للسياده وانما لمفهوم البيعه ان
القوى الغربيه خلال الفتره الاستعماريه
جردته من اجزاء كبيره من اراضيه وبتقول
فعلا ان المغرب عنده حق فيه شكوى من انه
جرد من اراد كان يجب ان تكون واقعه تحت
حدوده على كل الاحوال
التعاطف اللي واضح من فريق السي اي ايه في
هذه الفتره لم يكن قاصرا على المخابرات
الامريكيه ولكنه كان واضح ايضا في
المؤسسات الدوله الاخرى ومنها الخارجيه
الامريكيه في عدد كبير من الوثائق
وبالمناسبه رفعت عنه السريه بيكشف عن
تعاطف الخارجيه الامريكيه في هذا الوقت مع
الموقف المغربي احيلكم الى مثال واحد
اختصارا للوقت وهي وثيقه سجلت مداره في
لقاء جامعه بين الملكه الحسن في الرباط
يوم 15 اكتوبر 1974 وتحديدا الساعه
الواحده و15 دقيقه
وقتها كان وزيرا للخارجيه الولايات
المتحده اللقاء كان موضوعه مناقشه المواقف
المختلفه من الصحراء الاسبانيه كما كانت
تسمى لكن ما يهمني ان كلام كسر كان مثل
كلام السي اي 8 يفيض تعاطفا مع الموقف
المغربي من
ويشارك الملك والمغاربه بقناعته بعدم جدوى
انشاء دوله جديده لعدد محدود من السكان
الاصليين او الصحراويين الحوار الشيق اللي
انا هضع لكم روابته بيقول في مثل الملك
الحسن لقد اخبرت الاسبان عشان تفهموا
السياق يعني في هذه الفتره من الزمن اللي
هي 75 و 74 و73 كان الفكره ايه ما كانش
الصراع ما بين المغرب والجزائر كما هو
الحال الان ولكن كان الاول ما بين المغرب
واسبانيا لانه اسبانيا كانت عاوزه تخرج من
المنطقه والخيارات اترك هذه
الصحراء
الصحراويين وحق تقرير المصير ولا اتركها
للمغرب وكان في اتجاه تالت ان هي لا
تتركها اصلا يعني
الملك بيقول له
لقد اخبرته الاسبان انني افضل الوجود
الاسباني في الصحراء طبعا على منح تقرير
المصير او حق تقرير المصير ل 30 الف شخص
يعيشون في الصحراء
وكيسين بيرد بيقول له او يعني اثناء
الحوار بيقول له لقد سالني الرئيس
الجزائري بومدين عن رايي في ذلك في ذلك
وقلت له تقرير المصير مين سياده الرئيس هل
تسالني عن حق تقرير المصير ل 30 40 الف
شخص لا يعرفون حتى اين يعيشون ده رايي
كيسنجر معنى كده انه كان بيسخر من فكره
اعطاء الصحراويين حق تقرير المصير
بيكمل كلامه ويقول
انه طبعا الملك الحسن بيساله طب وابو مدين
رد عليك قال لك ايه قال له والله وهو واضح
انه معه حق تقرير المصير لكن اعتقد انه في
حقيقه الامر يريد منفذا على المحيط
الاطلسي بيقول نفس الكلام اللي قالته
المخابرات الامريكيه اللي هي متعاطفه مع
ايضا الموقف المغربي
وبيضيف من عنده كيسنجر الكثير من دول
العالم سخافات
يعني دول ليس لها مقاومات الدوله وبدي
امثله يعني ايه دوله تقوم فيه غينيا في
ساعه ولا في الصحراء الاسبانيه دي دول ما
تصلحش ان هي تكون دول عدد سكانها صغير
مقومتها صغيره
بالمناسبه لم يكن كسر يقول ذلك للملك من
قبيل اللياقه ويقول خلاف ذلك لغيره واضح
ان دي كانت قناع فعلا
لانه قرر هذا الكلام في لقاءات اخرى مع
مسؤولين غير مغاربه احيلكم الى مثال واحد
اختصارا للوقت في لقاء له مع وزير خارجيه
اسبانيا في تسعه اكتوبر 1974 وفقا لوثيقه
اخرى رفعت عنها السريه واضع لكم روابطها
او يعني لينكها للاطلاع عليهم كاسنجر قال
للمسؤول الاسباني اللي واضح انه سالوا
تكرارا ومرارا عن موقف الولايات المتحده
من الصحراء فكرر بشكل يبدي فيه مال له لقد
اجبتك عده مرات عن موقفنا من الصحراء لكن
بصفتي عالما سياسيا احب ان اخبرك ان
مستقبل الصحراء الاسبانيه لا يبدو رائعا
بشكل خاص اشعر بنفس الشيء تجاه دول مثل
غينيا بيساو او فولتا العليا في اشاره الى
ان دي الدول صغيره ليس لها مقومات الدوله
ولا يجب ان تكون دولا وبيقول له كده يمكن
للعالم ان يعيش بدون الصحراء الاسبانيه
وانا عشت فتره طويله من حياتي لم اكن اعرف
فيها اين كانت الصحراء الاسبانيه وكنت
سعيدا يعني ما فرقتش كتير
على فكره دي كانت طريقته يعني في الطريقه
الساخره دي كانت طريقه لكي سنجر في اداره
حواراته مع زملائه
المسؤولين في دول اخرى على كل الاحوال رغم
هذا التعاطف من جانب السي اي ايه ووزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه الى ان كل الادارات
الامريكيه المتعاقبه طبعا قبل ترامب رفضت
الاعتراف بسياده المغرب على الصحراء
وتمسكوا علنا رغم دعمهم وتعاطفهم سرا مع
المملكه بالموقف الدولي من الصحراء وما هو
الموقف الدولي من الصحراء باختصار شديد
مؤسسات المجتمع الدولي وعلى راسها الامم
المتحده لا تقر حتى الان بسياده المغرب
على الصحراء وتدرج الصحراء منذ العام
1963 في قائمه الاقاليب غير المتمتعه
بالحكم الذاتي ننسى
اي ان من يحكمها ليس اهلها وترى الامم
المتحده ان الحل هو في استفتاء على حق
تقرير المصير وفي هذا الاستفتاء يقرر
الصحراويين اما الاستقلال بارضهم او
الانضمام كجزء من المملكه المغربيه
معظم دول العالم والكيانات الكبرى بتتبنى
هذا الموقف للامم المتحده الدول الكبيره
زي روسيا زي الصين كل دول العالم تقريبا
الاتحاد الاوروبي مثلا بيتبنى هذا الموقف
وبتستخدمه مؤسساته احيانا لغه بتستفز
المغاربه لانه مثلا بعض مؤسساته زي محكمه
العدل تابعه للاتحاد الاوروبي بتستخدم في
احكامها اداه الصله
تعبير الارض المحتله لوصف الصحراء
الاتحاد الافريقي بيذهب الى ابعد من ذلك
لانه يعترف بالجمهوريه العربيه الصحراويه
باعتبارها عضوا كامل العضويه في الاتحاد
منذ العام 1983
جامعه الدول العربيه لم ترد ان تغضب
للمغرب ولا الجزائر فتفتق
ذهن الشاشه العرب عن عبارتهم المشهوره حين
يسالون عن الموقف من قضيه الصحراء يقولون
ان موقف الجامعه العربيه هو احترام سياده
وحده الاراضي المغربيه لكن دون ان يحددوا
اين تبدا واين تنتهي الاراضي المغربيه
وبالتالي كل طرف يفسره كما يشاء عوده
لموقف الاداره الامريكيه اللي هي الموضوع
الرئيسي للحلقه حين جاء بيضا اللي معظم
اقطاب ادارته كانوا يعارضون اعتراف ترامب
بسياده المغرب على الصحراء بيضا وجد نفسه
في مازق التراجع عن الاعتراف بسياده
المغرب سيؤدي بالتاكيد الى ازمه مع المغرب
وازمه مع المغرب تنتقل بالضروره او قد
تنتقل الى ازمه مع اسرائيل لان
[موسيقى]
الامريكيه المقترحه في مدينه الداخله
طبعا البعض ممكن يقول يعني وهي امريكا
حريصه قوي على سياسات الامم المتحده
واحترام القانون الدولي الاجابه نعم
الولايات المتحده حريصه على قواعد وقوانين
الامم المتحده والقانون الدولي الا اذا
كان لها مصلحه قويه في تجاوز قرارات الامم
المتحده والقانون الدولي وعندما توجد هذه
المصلحه تحاول امريكا ايجاد اي تخريجه
للتحايل على القانون وقرارات الامم
المتحده يعني لما ارادت غزو العراق هذا
انتهاك كل قرارات الامم المتحده وانتهاكوا
للمنطق وانتهاك لكل شيء ولكنها ابتدعت
طبخت سببا حتى ولو كان السبب واهي جدا هو
امتلاك العراق لاسلحه دمار شامل في حاله
الصحراء ليس لدى الولايات المتحده اي حافز
او مصلحه
لايجاد سبب للتحايل على قرارات الامم
المتحده واحد هذا الصراع المحدود وغير
مؤثر وغير مؤثر على بين غير مؤثر على
المغرب حليفتها اللي هي بتبسط سيطرتها
بالفعل على الصحراء وليس هناك ما يهدد هذه
السياده ثانيا
يعني من مصلحه الولايات المتحده ان تظل
القضيه معلقه ليه عشان تفضل تستغلها كورق
الضعت ضغط على المغرب وعلى الجزائر وعلى
كل الاطراف المعنيه لو افترضنا انها
حسناتها تماما لصالح المغرب سوف تفقد احد
اهم ادواتها لمساومه المغرب في المستقبل
ثالثا امريكا فعلا بتخشى من العواقب اذا
اقرت وباركت سياره المغرب على الصحراء
بالمخالفه لقرارات الامم المتحده التي تصر
على اعطاء الصحراويين حق تقرير المصير فان
موقف امريكا سوف يضعف كثيرا امام دول
مختلفه في العالم مثل روسيا والصين
وغيرهما هذه الدول قد تطالب المجتمع
الدولي وتطالب امريكا بالاعتراف بسيادته
على اراضها محل نزاعه زي شبه جزيره القرد
او زي شرق اوكرانيا كل هذه المواقف لم
تحرك الموقف المغربي قيد انملى هم متمسكون
موقفهم الدائم الصحراء مغربيه ولن يغيروا
ابدا موقفهم مهما كان موقف المجتمع الدولي
الفرق الوحيد انه المغرب الان بيطرح ومنذ
2007 فكره ان ينضم الاقليم الى المملكه
على ان يتمتع بحكما ذاتيا وهذه الفكره
بيدعمها عدد كبير من حلفاء المملكه
المغربيه والمملكه بتحشد كل جهودها لاقناع
اكبر عدد من دول العالم بان حل الحكم
الذاتي هو افضل حل ممكن لقضيه الصحراء لكن
هذا الحل بترفضه جبهه البوليساريو
وبترفضوا الجزائر اللي بتقول انا مع جبهه
البوليساري وبما ان جبهه وبترفض فانا ارفض
لكن المغرب بيراهن على استراتيجيه بتعرف
باسم سلامي اسلايسينج يعني ايه سلام
سلايسينج يعني محاوله تجاوز الموقف الدولي
العام المصمت وب الاقناع كل دوله على حده
بان الحكم الذاتي هو الحل الوحيد ونجحت من
2017 في تحقيق مجموعه من الاختراقات يعني
اكتذبت عددا متزايدا من الدول التي ترى ان
هذا هو الحل الوحيد الممكن لكن ما زال
امامها ايضا طريقا طويلا في اقناع عدد
اكبر من دول العالم بهذا الحل هل تنجح
لننتظر ونرى ويكون لنا مع هذا الملف المهم
حلقات اخرى باذن الله اشكركم والى اللقاء